the deepest the subconscious the true
motives that are driving a character can
never be and should never be explained
they should be implied what you do is
you put your character under pressure
when things are really at stake when the
forces of Life are compelling the
character to make a choice and take an
action in an effort to put their life
back into balance how that character
chooses that specific character what
they choose to do under that specific
pressure is who they are and as a result
the audience's mind or the reader's mind
goes through the surface and goes we
understand who they are by implication
of their actions you first of all have
to understand who your character is then
you have to put them under pressure let
them make choices take actions and
instantly if you do it beautifully
instantly the audience of the reader
wow and they get it